[Music]
America loves a
superstar I'm Jason two J's Jennings I
was a football legend but once you reach
the mountain toop of greatness everybody
wants to see you
fall two days this guy smoked damn you
plad guilty to charges of speeding and
damage to city property I'm recommending
community service with the Long Beach
Recreations department I thought I was
getting like some Martha Stewart kind of
treatment you too good for the community
that raised
you I am football legend Jason 2 J's
Jennings your new head coach Legend let
me get a picture with y'all real quick
for Twitter some of y'all going to get
some girlfriends with this right
here Keys Karine Jason I've been trying
to get back to touch you for years I
know you've been thinking about me and I
know you've been trying to get in touch
with me is that pretty much right you
just put a gun in my head relax Jay the
safety was on oh no it wasn't on what
imagine
that before we can be the best we got to
master the
fundamentals pretty boy you missing pass
after pass you got on all that sweet ass
swag the next time you come out here
acting like a fake ass rapper we going
to kick your ass off the field stop back
like you got an album coming
out JJ how you liking this game coach
this is a mess I don't know what I'm
doing do you remember what you were like
when you showed up freshman year you
were pain in the ass I don't owe nobody
nothing sound just like me if you really
want to win a game stop pushing away
your
team let's
go it look like a black princess layer
underdogs on three underdogs on Me 1 2 3
what's my name
[Music]
yeah I got your Mas guys right here be
killer and Siller two dos for two G's I
found them chained up in the back of the
winter
[Music]
snitch
p